Australia's most famous feminists
Germaine Greer has ruffled a few
feathers in her time most recently with
her opposition to the me to campaign and
her views on transgender rights but
she's also spearheaded a catalogue of
modern feminist thought and her book
change okay the change set out a
common-sense guide to life beyond the
menopause delighted that she is with us
night life beyond the menopause what
does it look like well it depends where
you are on the cusp or beyond or before
it can look profoundly dreary and you
can think that everything's over you
know my children have grown and gone and
and I can't get a job because I'm 45 or
50 and I don't have any ambition I don't
have any energy and besides which I
can't sleep and I keep bursting into a
sweat and hot and flustered there's very
good news about that by the way which is
that we found out what causes hot
flushes what it's actually well it's
probably not right to blame a neuro kin
in that we generate in our brain in the
hypothalamus but they found out almost
accidentally the way that happens that
you could provoke a hot flush using this
body chemical and that suggested a way
to control them once you know what
starts them you can know work out how to
stop them and that was being that work
was being done by julius break last talk
2015 now they're in the middle of
developing it for use by the public and
it's julius names kind of got submerged
in heavier names that belong to her
university of UCL and also probably i
suspect to the industry because there'll
be money involved now and the university
in the way of things has to maximize
that but it's there and it's coming and
for women whose lives are still a misery
from hot flushes because
for some women they will go on for the
rest of their lives they never stop and
that must be really wearing and it
undermines people's confidence you know
they start I mean it's a bit of a
challenge let me tell you when you on
the telly and you look like a rider but
a bucket of cold water thrown over you
but so I'm particularly interested in
this how would you describe yourself
I always describe myself as a feminine
feminist how would you describe yourself
I do my best to avoid describing myself
there are so many other people
describing me a I can't read what they
say because I might react to it I might
think oh yes that's how I want to be or
oh no I'll have to think of doing
something else so they won't call me
that I mean I've been called everything
just about there are people who think
I'm masculine there are people who think
I'm hysterical people who think I'm
unbearable I try not to think about it
which of us I don't want to be
self-conscious do any of them stink no
not really they they would if the people
were closer to me they would if there
were people who really knew me who's who
dismissed me in a word or two but when
people who've never met me have an
opinion it's not something I can respond
to I read that you were a major voice of
the second wave feminist movement in the
latter half of the 20th century you're
happy with that mantle well I'm about as
heavy as I am with things like Germaine
Greer as legacy so put up - excuse me
but I'm how does that manifest itself
though your your feminist movement
latter half of the 20th century how do
you see yourself as a flag carrier for
for women of a certain age I wouldn't
say that I've never thought of myself as
a leader when people say you changed my
life I beg them not to give me the
credit from what they did and I try to
get people to understand that I did the
best I could I wrote a book it's not a
very good book but women took to it they
read it and they made up for its
inadequacies and it did give them the
courage to make changes and to in
particular to change situations that
were not good for them they were making
them doubt themselves making them
lose their self-confidence making them
apologetic all the things we used to so
that's important don't I think of that
but there is a thing I was listening to
appears more than shouting yesterday
about how a new women want equality
therefore and going on and on about sue
Perkins and her sexist jokes at the
Baptists and saying you know and there
was a collage of all the things that she
said that annoyed peers it's so easy to
annoy peers it's quite difficult to
avoid it but and he was shouting about
how you want equality and you think you
can get away with doing this sort of
thing now I have never wanted equality
I'd have ice I don't see that the best
we can hope for is the lives that men
have under corporate capitalism I think
lots of men miserable in the corporate
world and the corporate world is quite
good at disappointing people and what we
what I want is freedom for women but
that's that's a difficult thing freedom
is strenuous and dangerous and you can
shrink from freedom but women haven't
done that the thing that really gets me
is that the women I talk to all the time
you know I talk every week or a couple
of weeks and lots of these women have
walked out of comfortable marriages
where they were miserable and have
really struck out for freedom they've
faced it all down you know they had half
the income they had before or less we
all know how difficult it is to get
child support so when you strike out as
a single mom a single parent you
actually enter a world of toil and
trouble and loneliness and no holiday
some things you can't afford and things
the kids want and so on and these women
have breasted it all they've just
accepted their new destiny and they're
different women they are strong and they
are optimistic and they're confident and
I'm really really impressed by them you
want equality in pay though don't you
you want us to be equal well that's a
curious thing I mean one of the things
super consid was something about don't
ask me how much i'm
let's say I'm putting in half the effort
and I thought now wait a minute sue in
the job you're in you bargain when they
ask you will you do the baptists for us
you say all your agencies if you're
clever you won't say so
and you actually negotiate a fee and if
your fee is not as great as a fee that
somebody else could negotiate regardless
of sex I would say then that's market
that's that's the business that you're
in and I think I think it's very strange
that all the jobs in say the television
industry would be phased according to a
rigid pay scale as if you were you know
working your way through the teaching
profession or something like that but on
average women earn 18% more less rather
than men and it's been illegal since the
1970s and yet it still happens what more
trees may should we do you know we've
got a woman a woman Prime Minister
surely she should be tackling that well
now you have to think about exactly what
that means as well I mean for lots of
women it's because they won't actually
work as many hours and they will have an
interrupted career because they'll be
raising children and so forth now the
thing that gets me is if you're if
that's your feeling that women should be
paid exactly the same as men over the
life career then I have to say okay well
in that case they must stop working for
nothing and you may say well what does
what do you mean working for nothing
I mean exactly that the unpaid work in
the world is done by women and it's
called housework and child raising and
dropping the kids of football or at
school it's it's all the unpaid work the
many many outlets you put in for your
family and we've got to do something
more hard-headed about that we've got if
you really want to make that out but you
have to say to the person you're sharing
a house with this is got to be even
Stevens because I'm already tired before
I go to work in the workplace they
should you know whether they've taken a
break of three months or three years or
whatever if they are doing a job that is
comparable to a man legally they should
be paid the same and they're not it
would appear
well now if we if we actually sink back
to the Equal Pay Act one of the worst
things that happened was that the the
elite trades unions arrived at a
formulation that they should have known
better than to adopt which was that
women would be paid equal pay for work
of equal value now every single trade
unionist knows that work has no value
work is worth what you can force the
employer to pay for it you have to use
collective bargaining as the bargaining
you have to use strategies and so on and
then you just negotiate so you've
reached the top of what is possible
given the economic realities of that
trade that you're in they were perfectly
happy for women in the trade union
movement to work for a fraction of what
the top earners in their trade union
were earning they built inequality into
the system which doesn't explain why if
you go and look at hairdressing for
example are the girls who are training
as hairdressers being paid the same as
the boys have they the same career
expectations and I think you'll find
that they don't you find that it's a job
they like it's a job they want to do but
they're not particularly ambitious so
it's women's faults that they're not
paid the same as men oh I wouldn't say
it's a fault
they are they actually live outside the
workplace as well as in it and I know
lots of men who don't really work
outside the workplace they come home and
fall in front of the television and lie
they're comatose until it's time to go
to bed they're not really putting the
full complement of energy into the house
I think we always say this that women
are multitaskers they are and men are
one-track mind errs it means they're
better at the things they do really well
but there are great many things they
don't do at all I would rather see us
thinking in terms of giving workers more
opportunity for creativity when you
think of it it always strikes me as
dreadful that the employer gets the best
hours of the day he gets
nine to five you get the sleepy bits at
the top and the exhausted bits at the
bottom and your family life and your
love life your sex life of your partner
have all got to happen in between these
things people who are tired you know
most men shave in the morning for they
go to work when they should be shaving
at night before they go to bed okay
meteor campaign Maura with that it's an
interesting question I don't really know
where we are with that are you with it
there are things about it I really don't
like you know I don't like the idea that
you 20 years ago
let's say you knew that your employer
had taken an unpardonable a pardonable
Liberty with a member of the staff and I
don't like the idea that you go and say
I know what you did and I'm going to
tell the newspapers unless you pay me to
keep my mouth shut
where I come from that's called
blackmail and I don't get non-disclosure
agreements I think they're dishonorable
and too many of the women entered into
them and now the statute of limitations
means you can't bring a prosecution if
you wanted a criminal prosecution it's
too late in some cases way too late I
mean in the case of Cosby for example
that was a civil suit brought by us can
turn against him she won that and the
states have now based their criminal
trial on that suit and they've got
themselves a conviction but there'll be
an appeal and it will go on and on and
on and my bet would be the Cosby work
won't outlast the way it goes I don't
think we can enter into that sort of
arrangement I think we've got it we've
got to kick ass and take names talk loud
and draw a crowd when it happens not 20
years later with people like you and me
would do that and I spoke recently about
a situation that happened to me and I
was very voluble about it at the time
but some women don't feel that they have
that voice and only when they hear about
others and they send the hen
the hashtag me too they feel that they
can then have a voice in numbers and say
what happened to them but it's still
difficult Rose McGowan who is a leader
in me too has just I noticed puts her
house in LA on the market it's been sold
for two million to pay the costs of her
civil suit against Harvey Weinstein now
that's what happens when you let the
time roll by and it makes everything
much harder we've been looking for ways
of making the charge against a predator
that would mean that other women could
know about it there's Callisto in
America but before that there were the
girls at Brown who put the names of the
worst offenders on the wall of a
washroom there are the women at Columbia
who did the same thing because one thing
you do notice if you spend time as a
university teacher as I did for most of
my life you realize that the Predators
on campus are a few and it's not true
that all men are rapists most men
probably aren't but the ones who are the
ones who are malevolent are repeat
offenders and the thing that's really
worrying if you don't start talking loud
and saying that man is dangerous avoid
him if you don't do that other women
will become victims as well because
these guys know the routine and the
routine is always the same now I wanted
to do it online years ago at Warwick 20
years ago and I thought you know all I
want you to do is is describe the
behavior and then we put it on the
website and a woman who's thinking of
going out with somebody but not really
quite sure can actually have a look and
see the way this guys like me to behave
I would have been happy for the name not
to have been mentioned just the behavior
if he says this if he does that if he
calls you a beautiful girl because he
can't remember your name be aware that
this is a recidivist this is a man who
habitually damages women you won't rape
not to be a crime cell right no
I don't want rape not severe crime
I don't want assault not to be a crime
the only thing is you thought it should
be labeled in a different way
no it's been labeled in every different
way you can think of and all that
happens is it gets more muddled no I
mean I think we've made a number of
mistakes when it comes to rape mainly
because the law was made by men and it
was about women as men's property that's
its history I think for example the
whole business of consent
I don't know if you saw today's news
story that in somebody in America was
saying we're going to have to ask our
babies for consent before we take their
nappies off so they learn consent from
an early age and you think when you
think of the things mothers have to do
involving that end of a child excuse me
would you mind mm-hmm mad crazy but the
fact is in a court of law you can't see
consent and it may very well be that the
perpetrator thinks that he had consent
and right percent of rape convictions
actually are proven and and they're
better then you'd say well then you've
got a problem have a look at who gets
convicted have a look at what they have
in common members of minority groups
poor many illiterate men and so forth
mentally ill men it's very hard to get
convicted as a matter of fact you'd only
need a reasonable defense because you
can always say even though you know the
girls 19 years old she was a virgin and
I did a tour in the back lane behind in
the nightclub and people think she was
up for it what it's not even probable
but as long as as the perpetrator
insists that what he thought even if he
was drunk you're not supposed to take
into account the fact that he was drunk
depending on the administration the fact
about the law of rapist it's different
everywhere it all turns on consent and
the thing that shocked me in the case of
the fall rugby players in Ireland is
that they behaved disgustingly and that
was pretty obvious all the details of
the actual behavior were read out were
accepted in court their text messages
were they boasted and so on
then the case dibs on the issue of
consent in a pathetic sort of way I mean
the young woman was being subjected to
an ordeal that she can hardly have
imagined let alone consented to it turns
on the issue of consent they decide that
they're going to be acquitted and
they're acquitted of all charges they
walk out of the courtroom with all of
them on their heads and not a moment
yeah to expiate it but the interesting
thing is what happened then the Irish
people turned against them but they were
all cleared on all charged they were all
clear
yeah they were I was tweeting that did
you really say let's talk about some
other women but and whether or not you
supported the women did you really talk
about Julia Gillard's backside in an
uncomplimentary way I didn't think was
uncomplimentary I said it was big
what's uncomplimentary about that it
might even be what's known as true no no
the thing had all began with her
bloodied jackets I couldn't bear the
jackets it's a bit like about a Theresa
Mays of golf ball necklaces and stuff
the giddy array of necklaces we get
three or four a day and each one is
worse than the last and you think you
know here I'm hoping that you're getting
somewhere with bricks it and all I can
see is most of your intellectual energy
is going to choosing yet another
necklace it's it's a way of it's a
criticism obviously but I don't think
because I'm a feminist I shouldn't be
allowed to make it the thing you hurt
Julia Gillard was that she had these
jackets which are like wine waiters
jackets there was a different one for
every day and it got taken out of the
box and she'd put it on and it they
never fitted properly they're always
either too tight here or too short there
and you need so would you have judgment
in the same way I suppose oh yes why not
of course the only thing is that men
don't look like anything they way they
can wear the same suit every day on TV
for example whereas you threw so hard we
have to wear a different dress every day
do you think that women become invisible
as they get older oh yes probably I
think they do
you can stand in a queue or stand at the
counter for half an hour and people pull
past you and in the end you have to
raise your voice which is the one thing
you're hoping no one rules what would
your advice be to women who feel that
they are becoming invisible as they get
older because I think that is semantics
but I think like you say you have to
raise your voice and you well I use all
sorts of different techniques so that
people take notice of me what about you
well I'm rather big I'm apt to block the
view
but it's places like the forecourt of
the garage when I can remember once I
was putting air in the tire of my little
Triumph Herald convertible and I
exploded it I blew it completely up
because I couldn't read the gauge
properly and I realized then that I'd
become invisible because even a month
before one somebody in the garage would
have come to help me but they didn't
that day and I blew up my tire so I had
to think about they're quite hard
you don't attract attention the way you
used to accept my life is a bit odd
because people these days more than ever
before something's happening out there
people come up and talk to me and say
you're my hero and all this sort of
thing I have to say please don't make me
your hero please I don't like ant handle
responsibilities oh it's other thing so
I have a sort of charmed life moving
through the public either people have no
idea who I am or they do know who I am
and they want to press my hand or have a
selfie or something and I I don't I
don't like it much I'd rather not be
noticed actually really oh yeah I love
being in a country where no one knows
who I am
love it Vanuatu for example not a soul
who I better final thought before we let
you go my favorite quotes is Madeleine
Albright I use it often saying there's a
special place in hell for women who
don't support other women do you agree
do I agree I would do I think that
Madeleine Albright's got the ticket to
hell
I think I probably don't agree I don't
agree that there is a hill and I don't
believe that the devil is in charge of
apportioning praise or blame here I
think we know manage with women's
support other women well it generally
speaking yes but not simply because
they're women but because they think
they're right or they think they're
getting a raw deal or they think they
haven't had a chance to put their case
but simply because a woman is a woman I
mean remember mrs. Thatcher them
whatever grand titles and things they've
got underneath that whole thing housing
yeah as far as the book is concerned the
change I'm guessing it's based on the
menopause and well it's all about the
menopause and it's about a being a
change in fact but it's a change that
brings you back to yourself in many ways
you spent your life working for other
people you know looking after our
partner looking after children carrying
out your job which is quite likely to be
a caring job and then you get to
menopause and in fact nowadays women of
course they're getting to menopause and
they've got children approaching
adolescence because they've given birth
select and they're thinking oh my god
and then at the other end the parents
are dropping off the twig and it's all
on them and it's hard and it is a rocky
trip for many people but you will get
through it you do crash a pain barrier
and you emerge stronger and you emerge
much more like the girl you were before
you became the tool of your reproductive
destiny you are that person that
inquisitive daring I could reamer I
agree Germaine Greer
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you
so much for joining us on ski ideas this
afternoon thank